foreign
kicks us off in San Jose Andrew welcome
to the show
thank you what's going on
so I'm having a really hard time getting
behind the idea of dropping my savings
down to a thousand dollars and trying to
pay off some debt I have okay
how much debt do you have well my
biggest
uh well I have two car uh payments one
of them is about twenty four thousand
the other one's about 72. oh I hope your
income is just baffling blow us away
what is it
uh my income is I think I made around
210 000 last year okay I feel better I
do feel better okay you're so you got
two car loans what else
that's it
do you need to do you need both cars or
is there another person in the picture
here
tell my wife has one eye or the other
okay and are you guys combining finances
so is that all of the debt between the
two of you that's all she says at home I
I work so tell us more about this this
issue with the the emergency fund the
thousand dollars saved so my guess is
you have a bunch of money in liquid cash
right now how much do you have
uh I have about 42 000. okay
and you want to get on the Ramsay plan
I do my biggest issue with it is is that
going under a thousand to me is just
scary especially when you have random
bills and expenses good example for me
is I had a dishwasher go out in December
and then I had a fence all over in the
last couple days yeah just to me going
down to that low is just I I don't know
if I can personally do that or not well
here's the thing it's not it's not it's
temporary it's not for the long haul
this is a very uh temporary action so
that it lights your butt on fire so that
you get this debt paid off super fast
and in your situation you've got a great
income you've got money saved there's no
reason that you can't get out of debt
very quickly to where that thousand
dollar emergency fund is a distant
memory and pretty soon you're going to
be up to having three to six months of
savings so it's not intended to be a
long-term fix and the reason we say that
is because it you know many people can
make the argument George that oh a
thousand dollars it's not enough what
happens if this happens or what happens
if that happens but the fact is 36
percent of Americans have no money saved
and those who have a little bit of money
saved they don't have a thousand dollars
56 percent of Americans could not pay
for a thousand dollar emergency so
Andrew that's why we have it set up that
way
um it's it's multi-purpose so in this
case is you knowing that you've got a
family you knowing these things you're
going to work even faster and be more
intent about getting out of debt and
here's the thing it's a thousand dollar
emergency fund but if something were to
happen you still have your normal
monthly cash flow right it's not to say
that you wouldn't be able to add more
money to that in order to make a repair
or make something happen I can tell you
from first-hand experience it took us
seven and a half years to get out of
debt we had 460 000 dollars of debt
Andrew we had a thousand dollar
emergency fund and do you want to know
what happened we'd use it and then we'd
have to replace it then we use it again
and have to replace it that's I mean
that's what it's there for and if it was
something that cost a little bit more
than what we'd have to do is we'd have
to sell something or find a way to get
that money and we always could
and I think that you'll be surprised at
how well that thousand dollars serves
you
and even for my area uh which is
generally a bit more than most it's a
thousand is still sufficient that you
find yep well it was never meant to be
sufficient because truthfully we go well
it should be 15 it should be three
thousand it should be six thousand yeah
you could say I mean a new roof is more
than five thousand so we should let's
make it ten thousand right so part of it
is to get people started on the plan
obviously you have an incredible income
and so let's just do some napkin math
here you said you've got 42 in savings
so if you took that down to one that
means you can throw forty one thousand
dollars at that ninety six thousand of
debt which means the first car is paid
off
and now you free up a payment and you're
left with 55 000 left right now you make
two uh 210 000 you could throw probably
ten thousand dollars a month at this
debt right
give or take the one thing I would say
is I get paid bi-weekly so technically
speaking I'm missing a portion of that
because I get two extra payments one
with a few different months sure so it's
slightly different is how that works out
but roughly each month you could
probably throw about 10K and so this
debt is if you do the Ramsey plan in
five months you're completely debt free
and then those next few paychecks
restock that emergency fund back up to
Thirty forty thousand dollars and so
we're talking a period of six to eight
months to do all of this that's right if
you get gazelle intents now the other
side is here would be is it might be a
little bit longer than that because you
have a mortgage payment to also take
into account and do it okay
and it's a reasonable mortgage
for your take-home pay
uh that's three thousand uh a month is
my current mortgage which everyone tells
me is good yeah I mean your take-home
pay is is what about 12 or more 15. yeah
it varies from yeah it's not 12 to 15
give or take California taxes they'll
get you then you're fine you're fine as
far as the percentage of engine mortgage
I mean think about what was saying if
you take that savings you knock out that
first car payment uh 24K how much was
the car how much is the car payment on
the car that's got the
that's worth 24 000.
uh the content is 500 a month you're
freeing up 500 a month right there just
right there if you had an emergency
suddenly you have fifteen hundred
dollars not just a thousand do you see
what I'm saying so it's kind of like
understanding that the thousand dollars
is there but you still have your income
you still have the money that you're
budgeting every month and there's always
something that you can cut down slim
back whenever you know if Murphy does
come into your house
a new budget this year I definitely have
wiggle room in my budget to pay more for
things so that's fine yeah no I think I
think that the baby steps works for
everybody you know everybody you know
it's it's fine to have questions about
it and we're happy to answer those
questions but I want you to go into this
Andrew knowing that this is the proven
method this is the smartest way to do it
and in your case like like George said
you're going to be out of this in six to
eight months
okay yeah let's go do it like Jade said
if something happens you get another
fence that falls down well we're just
gonna pause the baby steps and go all
right the next paycheck goes towards
replacing the fence that's right and uh
you don't lose any sleep over it and so
that's the the truth about the thousand
dollars is it's not as big of an issue
as people make it out to be because you
have future cash flow coming in that's
right and it's okay if you pause and you
know something else I like about the
thousand dollars saved George is it
forces you to calm down
to pause and think about your actions
because a lot of times something
unexpected happens and we think we got
to do it now you know and you start
spending this money you put on a credit
card you pull your savings but you want
to know what if your washer and dryer
breaks do you know what you'll be okay
you'll be okay for a while you don't
have to go to Home Depot that night and
replace it you don't even have to go
that week you want to know what I did I
drove over to my mother-in-law's house I
did my laundry over there until we had
the money it makes you wait it makes you
think
and I think we have the illusion of
safety when we have a pile of money in
the bank but yet we owe A lender ninety
six thousand dollars with interest it's
a facade I feel a whole lot safer
getting rid of that and uh being back in
control of my greatest wealth building
tool my income I love it we're rooting
for you Andrew thanks for the call